my picture of the week features Donald  Trump and Mitt Romney after a meeting to  discuss a cabinet role for Romney this  means that even his fiercest Republican  critics are eager to make nice with  Trump when jobs bacon it also means that  we shouldn't expect the Republican Party  to play a serious check on the incoming  president but we also shouldn't expect  Democrats to play that role they are the  minority party congress and will be busy  licking their wounds another thing we  have learned is that president elect  Trump is not that much different from  candidate Trump he holds few deep  convictions panders to his audiences and  cares mostly about himself all of this  means that it is even more important for  civil society in the media to hold Trump  accountable because if we have learned  anything from the rise of Trump it is  that it would be wrong to underestimate  him  you